i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation
tonight those who travel to the uk by
illegal and dangerous routes including
buy small boats across the channel may
be relocated to rwanda where they will
have their asylum claims considered i do
not support the removal to rwanda policy
on the grounds of legality practicality
and efficacy this agreement deals a
major blow to the people smugglers the
eve and their evil trade in human cargo
is very difficult for us you know this
is not the right you want our rights
the demands on the current system the
cost of british taxpayers and the
scandalous abuses are increasing the
british public have rightly had enough
britain is getting an opportunity to
dispose of asylum seekers
but they're not seeing
the life they're putting in
the home secretary wants to send asylum
seekers crossing the channel illegally
to be processed in rwanda
she says they'll get a fair deal and
that it will starve people traffickers
of their human cargo and so far the
courts have given her the go-ahead
the heir to the throne and the bishops
all disagree
they say that it's an outrage unlawful
brings shame to our nation and that
experience in australia shows that it
will cost millions we don't have to
spend
our choice is it right to make those who
landed over visit rwanda even if they
don't want to
or is there a better way
in the next 30 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight alexander downer who has
served as the australian foreign
minister and australian high
commissioner to the uk
and yasmin ahmed the uk director of
human rights watch um we do
unusually start with some common ground
nobody wants people to risk their lives
and nobody wants people to drown
anywhere never mind the channel and
second
i think there's no question about the
divisiveness of this issue
polling yesterday shows that 74 of
conservatives uh conservative voters
back the policy 71 percent of labor
voters oppose it but we're really
interested tonight in
whether
this policy can work and if it can work
is it right so let me start with you
alexander downer you were one of the
principal authors of the policy of
offshoring in australia
why do you think this approach works
well because it destroyed the people
smugglers business model i mean
basically what they were doing in the
case of australia is taking people
from different parts of the world i mean
substantially they came from the middle
east but they didn't all
um to indonesia
and then they were putting them on
small boats and bringing them across to
australia um so
we thought
uh that we had to break the back of this
business model
and by offshoring by in other words
sending a message that you can't get to
australia that way
um that would break the back of the
business model and and it not a hundred
percent but it substantially has it's
been pretty successful
was it a strategic decision or was it
just a reaction to i think there was one
particular boat wasn't there there where
they picked up 400 400 plus people
and uh the australian government just
said you're not coming
that's correct yes it was a it was a a
container ship called the tampa
um i think it was in 2001 and um it
picked up these people um was taking
them to indonesia the people overwhelmed
the crew on the tampa and demanded to be
taken to australia and the australian
government said that they would not land
in australia um so i was the foreign
minister at the time and the prime
minister said to me we better find
somewhere where we can send these people
to
and that took me a couple of days but
eventually i made an arrangement with
the president of nauru and
um they were they weren't all actually
sent to nauru or not all 400 but um
substantial numbers of them were sent to
nauru okay we'll come back and talk
about that in detail yasmine um
you're opposed to this policy
why and if not this what
so yes very fundamentally opposed as our
as we've you've spoken about many people
first of all it's cruel and inhumane
secondly it's unlawful people have a
right under international law to be able
to claim asylum in one's territory and
one and a country should not be
expelling people before people have had
the chance to claim asylum it is also in
the context of australia what we've seen
is extremely costly to the taxpayer and
it hasn't as mr downer said not it
hasn't been effective in the end whilst
there may be some figures that suggest
they're going down what we've seen again
and again is that when people need
protection and are seeking protection
they will do whatever it takes to be
able to seek that
but do you think that there
was uh some other way in which this for
example this both the tampa 430 i think
people were on it
could have been stopped what else could
they do
so i think the fundamental premise is
that people shouldn't be stopped the
idea that people should be stopped from
being able to claim asylum to be able to
claim and seek protection we have to
remember where this came from this the
whole system of protection was born out
of the second world war it was born out
of the holocaust where people were being
murdered and slaughtered and people
needed somewhere to get protection and
so a system was established whereby
states said that they would allow people
to seek protection in their territory
and that they would at least hear their
claims the whole idea is now is to expel
those individuals so they don't and i
think what we've seen is that there are
solutions so it's not like there isn't a
solution the solution is clear it's also
for governments to be able to provide
safe routes for people to be able to
come to their country we've seen some of
those established but they're certainly
not sufficient all right we'll talk
about this issue of safe routes and some
of the costs and so forth but let's just
start with the
question of effectiveness alexander
downer um in what sense did it work and
and why didn't it work completely his
usage uh well it it i'm trying to be
completely honest here there might be
occasional boats that have got uh at
least close to australia and have been
intercepted but in the main this this
trade has been stopped altogether i mean
we had thousands of people coming um a
year you might um you know get two or
three boats a year trying to make the
journey and by the way not from
indonesia they tend to be trying to make
the journey from sri lanka now but um
but substantially the trade has been
stopped there's no question of that
nobody in australia would argue with
that it has substantially been stopped
and more than that in australia unlike
in the uk there's bipartisan agreement
on this because these are not people and
this is a really important point to
understand these in the case of
australia are not people fleeing
persecution in indonesia just as the
people trying to get to the uk
are not fleeing persecution in france
they're not being persecuted in france
they are already protected
they just are destination shopping i
mean i'd rather live in britain no i'd
love to live in sheffield than in
liverpool or i don't want to live in
lyon so i don't like the the croissant
or something i mean you know in the end
in the end um
the obligation we have is to provide
protection for people the obligat we do
not have an obligation um to
bring them to our country as migrants
that's a completely different
proposition destination shopping to
adopt the australian
lexicon it's a bit rough isn't it
well it's exactly what's happening i
mean it look you have to have a frank
debate about this there's no point in
beating about the bush that is what's
happening in the case of the uk these
people wherever they originally come
from are coming to the uk making
dangerous journeys paying people
smugglers thousands of euros something
like 3 000 euros per person to make a
dangerous journey no not from iraq
they're making a dangerous journey from
france okay well we'll come back to all
of that but let's just stick for the
moment if from a uh yeah do you accept
that
it may not have been
a perfect success but the objective
which was to stop the flow of boats
uh actually
was realized
so i think it's interesting um because
uh alexander downer is characterizing it
originally as as the principal purpose
was for humanity to stop people
smugglers and stop people getting caught
within their web
and if that is the case if the purpose
is in fact humanity then we can see the
inhumanity that this causes and has
caused inauru since and in the other
places that the individuals from
australia have been uh sent to and
expelled to seven individuals have died
since that happened multiple individuals
including children have been subject to
inhumane and degrading conditions
they've been self-harm they've been
multiple other things so if in fact what
we're talking about is efficacy as part
of the question of effectiveness is
humanity and stopping inhumanity that
has been a complete failure but the
australian electorate
essentially
was worried if i remember correctly at
the time that there would be this
i use the word advisory tied of people
flowing onto shores and nobody knew what
to do with it so and somebody won an
election and i think but i think also
it's very important to put it in the
context of how many the the very very
small percentage of individuals that
come to the uk or australia who are in
fact needing protection the majority of
the refugees in the world are housed by
neighbouring countries who are
developing countries and themselves
don't have the capacity and what we're
seeing is countries like australia and
european countries pushing away refugees
and shirking their responsibility their
global responsibility i think what we're
looking at is we should be looking at
this in a global context and also just
to respond to alexander downer as well
in relation to the individuals most of
the individuals who are will go through
europe end up staying in the destination
in the country that they find themselves
in but there are individuals who seek
protection elsewhere and that is a right
underside under international law but
many do it for practical reasons if i
was an iraqi or an afghani refugee just
to stick on afghans afghans have been uh
for the beginning of this year to today
have been the most proportion of
refugees who've come to the united
kingdom or sought protection i wonder
why let's ask that question are these
people who are not legitimate refugees
or these people in fact who are now
fleeing the taliban
so the obligation under the refugee
convention is to provide people who seek
asylum with protection the obligation
isn't to take people as migrants from
different parts of the world and bring
them to your country so um you know the
simple proposition is there are 80
million or so people of something like
80 million people we say who are um
externally displaced people a few like
refugees
and we are obviously not going to take
all 80 million of them in the uk
um australia is not going to take all 80
million of them
so we have to have a system of managing
this whole issue of refugees you have to
have a system and one part of that
system
is to discourage people from making
dangerous journeys where lives could be
lost from countries where they are not
being persecuted where they are not at
risk of course it would be different if
people were being persecuted in france
and had to escape from france and this
was the only way to get to
get to safety was to come to the uk but
of course as i make the point these
people are not being persecuted in
france they just rather live in the uk
that isn't an obligation that we have in
international law the obligation we have
is to ensure that these people have
protection from persecution
genuine fear or personal institution
from that as an international lawyer i
say we do have there's no requirement
for a asylum seeker to stop in their
first country of uh arrival wherever
they arrive so in fact under
international law we do have that
opportunity under international law we
have an obligation we have an obligation
that they are protected we don't have an
obligation to turn them into migrants to
clarify
complete
perhaps to clarify you are both in some
sense right i think alexander you're
right the obligation under the uh
conventions is protection but i think
also
uh it is popularly thought and it was
true until brexit that actually doubling
the dublin convention meant that uh that
to the first country in which someone's
stopped uh would have the responsibility
and then and then they were to share
around you don't you don't lose or shed
your protection needs by virtue of
countries that you go through and that's
how international law works so you still
are in fear of persecution even if you
go through and what we've seen in the
united kingdom is that the majority of
people who try who have got come through
france who try to get to the united
kingdom they do so for very practical
reasons for like for example they have
family here so they want to reunite with
family so it's i think it's a a gross
missed character mainly they don't
though i mean i
80 of them have family here i think not
monomer and many i think they're very
very or might have of course some well
they know someone here so anybody who
knows or they might have one they should
be able to come to the uk they might
have i mean you know my mother-in-law
lives in derbyshire so me and all of my
children should be able to move to the
uk i mean it's you know it's not how
immigration policy works well well
interestingly as i noted before um the
majority of people who have come to that
who've tried to get to the uk through
irregular routes
uh this year have been afghans and many
of those individuals including it has if
you look at the students
actually they are overwhelmingly
iranians in iraq it's more than a half a
statistic more than half of people
home office statistics more than half of
the majority who have come across the
channel
they are not okay
iraqis and iranians
let's just deal with one aspect of who
these people are um
you said it's uh 3 000 euros in fact we
think now that the
payment to smugglers is nearer between
five and ten thousand
uh yes
is there a problem here that actually
we have millions of people sitting in
camps in lebanon for example uh who
would love to be able to come here and
some many have applied
yet
people can who can summon up that kind
of money get on these boats and
uh if there nothing
else is done they essentially get to
uh jump the queue
does that not worry you
well first of all i think there's no
such thing as a queue if you've been to
any countries where uh there's a lot of
g's but the the i do know what you mean
but i think it's important to say that
but but yes i think that the the the
fundamental principle is that
states should be providing safe routes
for people to come to their country so
for example in the united kingdom we
take about one thousand five hundred
individuals per year under humanitarian
so if we're gonna just stop you there
though the the point i'm really really
making is about this particular group of
people that this
set of flights this round the policy is
supposed to solve
aren't these people are these people
truly the most vulnerable if they can
summon up those resources to get across
the channel and pay by paying people
smugglers
do we really are we really meant to
believe these are the most vulnerable
people when there are other people who
we know uh
have uh fleeing war and so on well well
i think what we can say is that we know
the statistics show us that two-thirds
of the people who in the united kingdom
who come and seek asylum are in fact
deemed to be refugees that means they're
deemed to be in need of protection so i
think we can't make assumptions on the
basis of saying someone has more money
and therefore they don't have protection
needs if two-thirds of the individuals
that come here are in fact classified as
refugees in need of protection what it
does show us is that the majority of
people who come here are in fact in need
of protection so whether or not they
have the money to get here so i think
you know i think in inherently it's an
incredibly unfair system because people
who can afford to pay have an advantage
over people who can't it's also worth
noting that something like 80 percent of
all of the people who have been making
these channel crossings are are young
men
men under 40 years or under 35 years of
age um so i mean every picture tells you
a story and it explains to you what sort
of an
operation is going on here and the
people smugglers are selling this bill
of goods to these people they're
training them up for what they should
say to immigration officer to border
force officers on the boats as they're
coming across they throw their phones
into the sea they destroy their
documents i mean look if you were a
genuine refugee you wouldn't destroy
your documents or throw away your phone
you'd want to show people the evidence
of the genuineness well some big plans
people for good reason do lose their
documents let me ask you about don't
throw them away though but that's a
gross mystic characterization saying
have you been on one of those boats i've
said i've i've i've been to i've been on
i haven't traveled on one of them with
the refugees but i have been to a boat
yes i've been on several of them
actually i've got quite a lot of
experience at this issue
from which end have you been and spoken
to the detainees and immigration
absolutely i have absolutely spoken to
the board of police officers
and the statistics that i've been
quoting have been coming from no one's
very can i just say something that's
very interesting now that you raised the
border force which is really important
is the border force the union eighty
percent of the union
eighty percent of the officers
have supported their union the border
force 80 of border force officers belong
to the union no it's a very different
statistic and they have supported the
union's actions
to challenge the government in doing
this this is the uk civil service that's
absolutely
absolutely okay absolutely okay let me
add absolutely misrepresentation of the
people that work for them
by the way but this is
immigration is all about control let me
gain some control of this conversation
again let me ask you alexander um
this policy costs the earth uh the
australian refugee council
reckons that the australian government
spent the best part of eight billion
pounds on uh on its policy uh putting
people in nauru the papua new guinea
also until papua new guinea decided it
wasn't having any more of it um
isn't this taking a hammer to crack a
nut we don't quite know what's going to
happen tonight but there's a flight uh
on a plane that would take more than 100
people and the maximum number of
detainees that will go will be
seven or eight yeah so what you want to
do is stop the trafficking of people
into your country in the way that we've
been discussing and arguing about here
this evening
and um it's not a question it's not a
question of just doing the maths on it
it's a question of stopping it happening
and in australia's case it
overwhelmingly has been incredibly
successful which is by the not just the
former government the liberal party
which is like the conservative party but
by the why the labour party supports the
continuation of this policy um it's it's
cost i mean that figure you can imagine
is a huge exaggeration but it has been
expensive but how much would it cost to
do absolutely nothing to allow tens of
thousands of people to embark on these
dangerous journeys on i mean possibly
hundreds of thousands of people on these
dangerous journeys to come into our
country people dying search and rescue
trying to save people okay um boats
washed up against the cliffs on
christmas island uh okay okay
yes man well i think your your
fundamental point is correct it is an
incredibly costly system and i think
what alexander has made very clear is
it's uh it's designed not necessarily in
the interest of the taxpayer it's
designed to
stop something starting to stop and be a
deterrent um and what we've seen is
millions and billions of dollars being
spent on this uh in the name of in
australia australian taxpayers as
opposed to and particularly at a time in
the uk where we're going through now a
cost of living crisis in how in what
name does pretty patel and boris johnson
think that they should be spending what
will be billions of pounds sending
people to rwanda
rather than spending that money on the
people who don't have adequate homes in
the united kingdom mind you it's the
first time i think i've ever heard
people from the political left say that
they want to exercise fiscal restraint
normally they want to spend more money
on absolutely everything oh except for
running a proper immigration program
which you know i would say whatever if i
can just say it just does expose their
basic agenda their agenda is to allow
anyone to come into the country without
any proper controls at all without any
problems i would ask them so what what
do you say then alexander should be the
solution to say the situation in
afghanistan where we as the united
kingdom in australia were in afghanistan
for decades where we had afghanis work
for us
in our interests while we were there and
there are now thousands and and
the answer to your question what is that
your concert your your chris the answer
to your question
is that we um should have a resettlement
program for people who have assisted us
in afghanistan and
and
in the case of australia we do have a
resettlement programme and the case of
the uk they too have a right to so the
research
so the next argument is not uh it's not
i think
absolutely the whole of afghanistan
wouldn't not big enough
no but i think you're that we we get to
common ground here we get to common
ground here to say that the governments
need if they're if they are truly
genuinely like you say worried about
individuals it's it really is about
people smugglers and people being hurt
as a result of that then the answer is
to have proper
proper resettlement schemes whereby
you're taking a proportion of
individuals we have agreed to take 20
000 individuals from afghanistan here
and we the and the for example canada
has taken 40 000 have doubled what we're
taking
it is no surprise that the majority of
people who have come to the united
kingdom in the first half of this year
have been from afghanistan so what i'm
saying is absolutely the common ground
is governments if really your motive if
government's motive is humanity and
stopping people smugglers established
proper so let me let me just explain we
have
in the case of australia look look
you had a great go there but in case of
australia
well it's rude to interrupt um so in the
case of australia we take around 20 000
refugees every year we have a refugee
resettlement program we had a special
one for afghanistan after the biden
administration walked out in disgrace it
was a stressful thing to do to walk out
of afghanistan um so we take re-resettle
about 20 000 refugees every year in the
case of the uk i'm not sure what the
number is but um the point i make is
that it is a good idea to have a
resettlement program for refugees if
it's an orderly resettlement program but
we can't take all 80 million of them so
there has to be a limit and the question
the question is how do you define the
limits and how do you deal with the huge
numbers that potentially are involved
here and the one thing you do want to
stop people doing
is taking unnecessary and huge risks
with their lives uh yes when one uh
there's part of the program this program
where we always get to where trevor
tries a third way and everybody and
everybody says that for rubbish um
but let me try very briefly one uh the
court will rule on the
overall
um
validity of this scheme within the next
month um
there's been frantic efforts to try to
stop this particular flight doesn't it
make sense to say okay fine
the randons
you know people might have to go and
stay in the hotel we've been seeing on
television for a month but if the courts
say the scheme is not valid they'll have
to be brought back
wouldn't it make sense to everybody to
calm down a bit step back let the courts
do their job
and then decide what to do rather than
trying to stop this flight now
well i think what we've missed in this
debate so far which is great that you've
come to it is actually the situation for
asylum seekers in rwanda so what we as
human rights watch have documented is
the persistent and systematic
uh violation and human rights abuses
that occur in rwanda to individuals
particularly individuals that may have
opposing
views to kigami and the current ruling
party we know that bloggers
politicians uh any individuals that
speak out against the government have a
number of individuals have been
imprisoned subject to torture they've
raised this in corporate settings and
nothing has happened we know that
indefinite detention torture is routine
in a number of these cases so what we
are saying and i mean just in
specifically in relation to uh refugees
in 2018 the last time the refuge
refugees in their country themselves uh
had a sort of protest and race concerns
nine refugees were killed at that time
by the authorities and 19 were detained
we are we are pretty much out of time uh
alexander
15 seconds on rwanda where i know you've
been
i've been to rwanda it's a beautiful
country and it's an extraordinary
achievement the way it's been rebuilt
out of the civil war of 1994
the unhcr uses
rwanda as a destination for refugees
they look after refugees there but look
in the end if these people who want to
make a dangerous journey um across the
english channel don't want to go to
rwanda they can stay in france so they
do have a choice france or rwanda of the
two i'm not sure which i would choose
but i don't think it uh befits people to
be so endlessly patronizing about rwanda
i think this is nothing about
patronising this is about the facts on
the ground all right uh i normally at
this point have to sum up this week it's
it's really really easy you both agree
that the system is unfair you both agree
it should be orderly from that point on
you agree about nothing we both come
from the same hometown uh you don't
agree about rawanda maybe oh yeah maybe
they should be always be sent to
adelaide that would be fun
we have a detention center we don't want
to send anyone to there thank you to
both of my guests stay with us we'll
have all of today's news coming up after
the break
[Music]